it's been 30 days since Uranus first
appeared in the
sky at first it looked like our moon had
found itself a stellar partner Cal but
then we understood something much much
bigger was headed our
way what caused Uranus to become so
unstable
how could this epic Collision change the
ice
giant oh and what's this horrific
stink
G this is what if and here's what would
happen if Uranus collided with
Earth let's roll back 30 days when
things were still normal Uranus lived a
quiet life on the outskirts of our solar
system about 3 billion I km away from us
and then suddenly it began to move
closer astronomers would be the first to
push the panic button by their
calculations it would take Uranus 13
years to reach the Collision Point we'd
be short on time but at least we'd have
a slight chance to evacuate the
Earth but the cold blue giant had other
plans in mind
this would be no standard planetary
drill planets don't just take off from
their orbits for no reason at all but
somehow Uranus
did now it would be hurdling through the
solar system ramping up to a speed of
around 1,000
km/s because of this unexpectedly fast
speed we'd only have about 30 days left
on this
planet Uranus would shine like a bright
blue star in the sky and every day it
would appear bigger and
brighter our Sky would look gorgeous not
only because of the ice giant shining
down on us but also thanks to many
shooting stars only those wouldn't be
stars at
all to get to the Earth's orbit Uranus
would have to pass an asteroid belt
between Jupiter and
Mars This would disrupt the stable
orbits of many asteroids and throw some
of them our
way these asteroids can be as big as
240 km in
diameter that's a few times larger than
the one responsible for wiping dinosaurs
off the face of the Earth about 65
million years
ago we would have nowhere to go we'd
just be left here watching the end of
times unfold in front of our
eyes might as well enjoy the
view by the time the first asteroids
appeared as shooting stars Uranus would
look about the same size as the moon but
it would be growing rapidly as it moved
ever
closer while you'd be here awaiting
Humanity's Doom Uranus would start
shaking things
up because UR is about 15 times more
massive than the earth its gravitational
pull would start massively affecting our
planet volcanoes would begin erupting
uncontrollably and tremendous
earthquakes would get in on the ACT
destroying the Earth from the
inside and the
stink you drop unconscious from even one
whiff of it because well I mean Uranus
smells like like
farts the ice Giant's upper atmosphere
is mostly composed of hydrogen sulfide
it's the same stuff that makes rotten
eggs rig so bad imagine an entire planet
of rotten eggs engulfing the
Earth the thought of it makes me
[Music]
nauseous but Uranus wouldn't come alone
it would bring all of its 27 moons along
for the ride and those moons would be
hitting the Earth from all
sides as a fart filled finale Uranus
would compress what was left of our
atmosphere and the rapidly Rising
temperatures would ignite
it just like that our beautiful blue
planet would fall in line and start
circling the ice giant eventually
becoming one of its many moons
Uranus wouldn't get away with this
assault so easily however last time it
collided with another planetary object
twice the size of Earth it tipped over
yeah Uranus is the only planet in our
neighborhood that spins on its
side this impact featuring our Earthly
home could help tilt it back to how it
once
was but for the Earth we know that would
be it if by some unexplained mystery
life on Earth's stinking leftovers
emerged once again we would see the blue
of Uranus on the
horizon the two biggest planets in our
solar system in one telescope view
catastrophe is imminent if Jupiter and
Saturn suddenly were on a collision
course which of the two planets would
emerge
Victorious how would the composition of
these planets affect the
outcome and what impact would this have
on the rest of our solar
system this is what if and here's what
would happen if Jupiter and Saturn
collided on December 2st 2020 Jupiter
and Saturn were closer than they've been
in nearly 400 years this legendary event
has an epic name the great
conjunction you could see both planets
in the same telescope view they appeared
as a single star in the evening sky but
they were still pretty far from an
astronomical Collision if the two gas
giants came a little closer it wouldn't
be the first time Jupiter has gone
head-to-head with another planet and you
can probably guess who won that
battle both Jupiter and Saturn are
almost entirely gaseous primarily
consisting of hydrogen and helium and
while they may have solid cores there's
no sharp transition between the layers
Jupiter would have some significant
advantages it's about three times as
massive as Saturn with almost double the
volume and it's moving faster too
Jupiter's rotation speed reaches 13 km/
second while Saturn rotates at just
below 10 km/ second but Saturn brings a
wild card to the fight within its two
rings there are at least
150 moons and
moonlets if the planets Drew closer
together Jupiter's strong gravitational
pull would cause these moons moonlets
rocks dust and Ice to accelerate toward
it some of them would be torn apart
that's what happened when the comet
Shoemaker levy9 collided with Jupiter in
1994 originally the comet was nearly 2
km wide but by the time it crashed
Jupiter's gravity had torn it to pieces
and those fragments smashed into Jupiter
with the force of 300 million atomic
bombs yeah and that heated Jupiter's
atmospheric temperature to nearly 40,000
de C Titan Saturn's largest moon is over
2,000 times larger than that Comet so
the force of it alone colliding with
Jupiter would be massive if Jupiter and
Saturn collided they would begin to
merge their atmospheres would mix that
would raise the temperatures in the top
layers of the gas giants
atmospheres it would get so hot that
Jupiter would experience a chemical
reaction gaining more iron silicates and
even water eventually Jupiter would
absorb Saturn or most of it scientists
at sunat sen University in China modeled
a scenario about what happened when a
massive planetary embryo about 10 times
the size of Earth collided with Jupiter
4 and2 billion years ago the impact was
so energetic that it destroyed Jupiter's
original compact core this formed a more
diluted core composed of a dense mix of
liquid metallic hydrogen and helium but
if Jupiter collided with Saturn that
event would be 10 10 times more massive
large amounts of material would spread
out in space and then all that material
would come together into a single
planetary object we'd call it new
Jupiter or
jupitus and maybe that new planet would
cause more trouble in the solar system
than you might expect Jupiter is
sometimes referred to as a failed star
that's because its size and composition
are similar to a brown dwarf but jupitus
would be more massive and have higher
internal pressure if the temperature was
high enough this could cause nuclear
fusion in its core yeah jupitus could
become a star and the impact of having
two stars in our planetary neighborhood
would be huge it could even mean the end
of life on earth now don't worry if
these two planets merged jupitus would
have a mass 30% greater than Jupiter but
for nuclear fusion to ignite the planet
would need to reach a mass of 75
Jupiters so life on Earth would go on
but this would be a spectacular show
with tons of gas and debris expelled
maybe it would all be illuminated by the
sun giving us a beautiful glittering end
to Saturn as we know it it's time for
one of the biggest battles our solar
system has ever seen in this corner a
gas giant and heavyweight
Jupiter and in this corner an infinitely
small but truly terrifying black
hole what would happen to these Rivals
as they hurdled toward each
other why would would this event cause
earth to be bombarded by
asteroids and would it be game over for
our solar
system this is what if and here's what
would happen if Jupiter collided with a
black
hole okay before the fight let's take a
quick look at exactly what each
Contender is up against starting with
our solar systems favorite Jupiter is
the fifth planet from the sun located
about 740 million kilomet from it this
gas giant is the largest planet too it's
about
3188 times more massive than Earth and
twice as massive as all the other
planets in our neighborhood
combined but looks can be deceiving
compared to its opponent the heavyweight
Jupiter isn't all all that heavy Stellar
black holes are a lot smaller than our
gas giant but they sure can pack a punch
the thing about black holes is that they
are dense incredibly dense all of their
matter is contained within an infinitely
small Point known as a
singularity and inside this tiny region
all concepts of time and space follow
apart and like any object with mass
black holes have gravity a lot of
gravity most black holes are remnants of
massive stars they're called Stellar
black holes and they range from 3 to 10
solar
masses but because they're so dense if a
black hole with 10 times the mass of our
sun appeared in our solar system it
would only be 60 50 km
across so would our gas giant Jupiter
stand a chance to defeat its Tiny But
immensely powerful Contender or would it
just be another object lost inside the
black holes point of no
return everything in the universe is
moving through space at break neck speed
and naturally that includes the sun and
the rest of our solar system we're
whizzing AC AC cross the cosmos at about
720,000 km an
hour and in this Galactic dance another
star may come close enough to us to
influence the outer regions of our solar
system or Worse we might run into one of
the nearly 1 billion black holes
rampaging around the Milky Way
galaxy of course the chances of this
happening are slim the closest star in
our neighborhood is over four light
years away and that's far scientists
think that there's only a 1% chance that
another star will ever come close enough
to disrupt the edges of our solar system
the chances of a rogue star coming close
enough to mess with Jupiter are even
lower but it could
happen at first as this stealthy force
of Destruction swung toward us the black
hole would disrupt the or Cloud this
area surrounds our solar system like a
giant spherical shell and it's filled
with icy
objects but these mountain-sized ice
cubes would be no match for a black hole
as they were pulled along for the ride
with this small but massive monstrosity
this would be the first sign that an
epic collision with Jupiter was
unavoidable
the gravitational Intruder would
continue through the next region the
Kyper belt and it would wreak havoc
along the way many of the icy objects
here including the dwarf planet Pluto
would be ejected from their
orbits things would suddenly get more
serious for Earth as many of these
objects would now be on a deadly
Collision Course with
us as it passed Neptune Uranus and
Saturn the black hole would tear away
their
gases these gases would form an
accretion disc of superheated gas and
dust around the gravitational Intruder
and if the black hole came too close to
any of these planets they could also be
at risk of being ejected from their
orbits then the black hole would finally
Bear Down on Jupiter and right away the
gas giant would experience a similar
attack on it its
atmosphere the black hole would pull
away hydrogen and helium gases like yarn
from a yarn ball eventually the entire
planet would be pulled toward the black
hole it would be an unfair fight from
the get-go Jupiter wouldn't even be able
to get a punch in and if all this isn't
violent enough just
wait as this dense and hungry monster
chowed down on Jupiter's abundance of
gas it would also release an explosive
wave of UV and x-rays in all
directions yeah it would be like one big
super massive burp packed with deadly
radiation this radiation would hurdle
toward us on Earth in less than an hour
lethal amounts of radioactive material
would rain down on us but on the bright
side you'd finally be able to see the
black black hole up in the
sky whatever stability we enjoy in our
solar system would be gone the black
hole would be swallowing up everything
in sight including our
planet now if we somehow managed to be
spared the full brunt of the black
hole's destructive forces well without
Jupiter our solar system would need to
find a new gravitational
balance yeah Jupiter had a special place
in our neighborhood its enormous gravity
kept asteroids and comets from pummeling
us and other in planets of our
neighborhood it also helped Earth
maintain its nearly circular orbit
around the Sun so even if we survived
all the gravitational Havoc from a rogue
black hole without Jupiter this little
space Rock we call home wouldn't last
long
this pretzel shaped collection of
galaxies is our universe and it's about
to collide with another
Universe it might be fascinating to
watch but we should probably be worried
about what's going to happen when they
crash how would it change the physics of
our
universe is there any chance that we
would
survive what would the Collision look
like from Earth and has it ever happened
before this is what if and here's what
would happen if our universe collided
with another
one the only potential evidence of a
universal Collision that we've ever
discovered is in the form of a cold spot
in our universe in 2013 1 the European
space agency's plank satellite confirmed
that this area is 1.8 billion Lighty
years across it's much colder than the
rest of space and it seems to be missing
10,000
galaxies at first scientists were
baffled by its existence but now some
have theorized that this spot might be a
kind of Scar or bruise left from
colliding with another universe
but how can we know for sure and if this
is the case how long before it happens
again before we go any further let me
take a second to address something that
might have some of you scratching your
heads usually when we refer to the
universe we're talking about all space
and time including planets Stars
galaxies and all other forms of matter
and energy so if the universe basically
means everything in existence then
logically there can only be one of them
right not
necessarily some scientists believe in
the concept of the
Multiverse this theory states that our
universe wasn't the only one that popped
into existence during the big bang that
there's an infinite number of other
universes out there too and we just
haven't found a way to see or measure
them yet if this Theory is right then
it's possible that all these other
universes could have grown at the same
rate at the same time after the big bang
if that's the case then they might have
banged into each other as they expanded
and that brings us back to the cold spot
the cold spot is a region of our
universe that's
0.0015 de colder than everywhere else
that might not seem like a big deal but
when the rest of the universe's
temperature is so con consistent
scientists have started to think it's
something more than an anomaly they
think that the cold spot might be a scar
left over from a collision between
universes and the Crash might have moved
a bit of energy out of that spot in our
universe causing the colder temperature
but what would a collision of that
magnitude look like well we can't say
for sure but there are some pretty cool
ideas out
there according to one physicist at the
University of California if another
Universe came crashing into ours it
would look like a giant mirror in the
sky rushing towards us because its wall
would reflect light if this other
Universe collided with our own we could
inherit a whole new set of governing
laws of physics gravity could weaken or
disappear resulting in a slew of planets
escaping the gravity of Their Stars
sending them flying off off into space
at ridiculous speeds without gravity
Stars would cease to exist and we'd be
left in Perpetual
Darkness this would make life on Earth
and throughout most of the universe
nearly impossible with no shining stars
we'd lose any means of nourishment or
breathable air as plants would no longer
be capable of transforming Starlight
into energy through
photosynthesis but as bad as that all
said sounds it's not something we really
have to worry about since the chances of
our universe colliding with another one
are slim to none for one thing we're not
even sure that there are other universes
out there to collide with and even if
there are any collisions would have
happened at that point when they were
expanding 380,000 years after the big
bang which would mean there's little to
no chance of it happening again
it's all over for
Uranus the ice giant is locked into a
collision course with the king of all
planets in our solar system
Jupiter what would happen as the two
planets made their epic
approach would Uranus get pulled apart
into bits and
pieces or could this ice giant somehow
deal a mortal blow to its gigantic
opponent
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter and Uranus
collided okay let's get to know our two
planetary prize Fighters a little better
you know before they both potentially
get blown into
Oblivion first Jupiter the largest
planet in the solar system put all the
other planets together and it's still
twice as massive but this monstros has
no solid surface it's nearly all gas
mostly made out of hydrogen and
helium in the other corner of the ring
is
Uranus even though it's three times
smaller and 20 times less massive than
Jupiter it's the third largest planet in
the solar system so don't let the size
difference fool you underneath Uranus's
hydrogen and helium atmosphere there's
an abundance of Water Ice
that's why Uranus isn't a gas giant like
Jupiter it's an ice giant like its
neighbor
Neptune of all the planets in the solar
system Uranus is unique it rotates on
its side all thanks to an earth-size
object that slammed into it billions of
years ago so could the most epic
Collision in the history of collisions
end with Uranus getting knocked right
side up you likely don't track Uranus's
whereabouts in the night sky but if you
did you'd be in for the realization that
the icy planet has somehow slipped out
of its usual orbit commencing countdown
to
Collision on its way toward Jupiter
Uranus would first need to survive a
close encounter with the gas giant next
door Saturn with all its colorful rings
and many moons Saturn is twice as large
as the stinky Blue Planet but the two
planets have very similar gravitational
pulls so as they just barely brush past
one another Well Uranus could end up
sweeping up a moon or two to add to its
current collection of
27 Uranus would now be barreling down
onto its opponent the closer it gets the
clearer the picture would become of just
how incredibly enormous that opponent is
Jupiter is over 20 times as massive as
Uranus and even though it doesn't
technically have a surface its surface
gravity is more than twice as
strong maybe Uranus was barking up the
wrong planetary tree except it's too
late to turn back now besides you've got
front row seats to this epic fight it
wouldn't be smooth sailing right up into
Jupiter's atmosphere first Uranus would
have to Elbow its way through some of
Jupiter's 80 moons the first of these
would be
pacifi there wouldn't be too much to
worry about here pacifi is very small
it's more than 60 times smaller than our
moon Uranus would pass right by it and
the remaining Minefield of Jupiter's
moons completely
unscathed okay now the planetary
heavyweights would be getting close but
how this Collision would unfold would
all depend on Uranus's angle of
impact if it somehow managed to slip
into Jupiter's orbit then the two would
be on course for a head-on collision in
this event the atmospheres of both
planets would compress as they came into
contact this would result in both of
their temperatures rapidly increased Ing
and then
boom no no I'm just kidding with no
oxygen on either Planet they wouldn't
ignite in fiery
explosions but if you're only in it for
the spectacle well don't worry the
Collision would still be very violent
the two planets would make full body
contact combining their Mass along the
way like a Janus or a maybe a
Jupiter one thing that wouldn't happen
though is Jupiter turning into a star in
order to become a brown dwarf it would
need to weigh 13 times more than it does
now or 85 times more if it wanted to
become a low mass
star sadly adding Uranus under its belt
would only increased Jupiter's mass by a
fraction now more realistically Uranus
would hit Jupiter from the side this
Collision would also begin with the two
atmospheres compressing except instead
of merging into one they'd both remain
somewhat intact but have a lot of their
gases thrown off into space so after
this epic encounter we'd still be left
with eight planets in the solar system
though these two would certainly look a
little different Jupiter would look like
a thinner version of its formerly huge
gassy self and Uranus could end up being
not much more than a solid Rocky core
covered in water and ammonia if things
unfolded like this then that could leave
Saturn to take over the Throne of
largest planet in the solar
system in the center of our galaxy The
Milky Way There is a super massive black
hole feeding on nearby Stars
it's called Sagittarius
AAR and if a giant gravitational monster
slowly eating the Galaxy isn't
terrifying enough there's another Cosmic
monstrosity lurking around
it is it possible that one day they
would get a little too close and
collapse on each other what would be
left of the Milky Way if they did would
there be even a slight chance that the
Earth could get out of of that
safely this is what if and here's what
would happen if a magnetar collided with
a black
hole this monstrosity creeping through
the Milky Way is a remnant of a giant
exploded star but it's not just any
Remnant it's an extremely dense and very
magnetic collapsed Stellar core a
magnetar Let me refresh your knowledge
of
magnetars they're born when a star at
least eight times more massive than our
Sun reaches its expiration date and
explodes in a beautiful
Supernova much of that star is gone but
the dense core of it remains most of
these remnants become neutron stars they
spin very fast usually a few times per
second and they're composed of
neutrons some neutron stars have such
strong magnetic fields that they emit
electromagnetic radiation from their
poles that makes them pulsars and you
can observe them with a telescope when
their poles face the
Earth only a few pulsars develop such an
extremely powerful magnetic field they
become the strongest magnets in the
universe the
magnetars they spin once every 10
seconds but their magnetic field is a
100 times stronger than that of a
neutron star if one of those magnets
came halfway between the Moon and the
Earth well it wouldn't be
pretty but would it be as bad from a
distance of 26 Lighty years
away well what I'd like to know is would
a magnetar swallow a black hole or would
a black hole gobble up a
magnetar the Collision of these two
giants
wouldn't end up in an explosion but in a
quiet Cosmic merger stretched over
billions of
years although magnetars are incredibly
powerful they would lose the battle with
a black
hole depending on the trajectory of the
magnetar as well as the size and mass of
both the magnetar and the black hole the
magnetic monster would be eaten up
either whole or slowly piece by piece
as the magnetar was being torn apart by
the black hole it would be sending
gravitational waves throughout the
Universe disturbing the curvature of
SpaceTime once the black hole consumed
the magnetar its mass would increase and
expand its Event Horizon and thanks to
this expansion more and more stars would
be flung into its dark
density the black hole would be slowly
eating our galaxy Star by
star eventually after quadrillions of
years of star consumption the black hole
could gobble up the Milky Way all of
it by that time humanity would most
likely be long gone
anyway the biggest planet in the solar
system has gone Rogue and now it's
heading straight toward Earth you have
30 days till this gas giant wipes us all
out what speeds would Jupiter be
traveling
at what kind of Havoc would it wreak
along the
way and is there any way we could
survive getting eaten by a planetary
Pac-Man this is what if and here's what
would happen if Jupiter collided with
Earth in our night sky Jupiter appears a
lot like a bright star from our Earthly
point of view only Venus and the moon
are
brighter but something strange is going
on 588 million kilm away Jupiter has
ramped up its speed to 200 25 km/ second
that's 15 times faster than its usual
orbital
velocity so now this gas giant 11 times
larger and 317 times heavier than Earth
is on the loose and it's going to speed
right at us until it's filled up the
entire night
sky but don't worry you could already
already be dead long before those 30
days are
up as it moved toward Earth Jupiter
would first pass through the asteroid
belt this region between Jupiter and
Mars consists of hundreds of thousands
of Rocky bodies ranging from Tiny dust
particles to asteroids almost 1,000 km
in width but none of these would do
anything to slow down the gas giant the
average distance between these asteroids
is about equal to seven Jupiters in a
row so there's a chance the planet could
pass through completely
unscathed and in our night sky Jupiter
would now look double its usual size
which doesn't seem like a whole lot to
make everyone panic but that doesn't
mean it wouldn't cause a little bit of
chaos on his trip you see Jupiter is is
vital to our solar system and to life on
Earth it acts as a gatekeeper to our
cozy planetary neighborhood protecting
us from being bombarded with giant
life-ending asteroids all the
time why well because Jupiter's
gravitational pull is massive about four
times stronger than Earths this strong
pull redirects asteroids that could be
on a collision course with us and this
is good news for you because even one
asteroid as small as 5 km across could
end life on Earth as you know it just
like what happened to the dinosaurs
around 66 million years
ago but if Jupiter suddenly started
heading toward the center of the solar
system it could send many dangerous
space rocks our way if one of them
smashed into Earth you might not live
long enough to see Jupiter swallow Earth
but for the sake of our hypothetical
scenario let's keep you alive for
now while sending asteroids on a
collision course with Earth Jupiter
could also pick up a new moon or two the
asteroid belt is home to the only dwarf
planet in the inner solar system series
it has about 25% % of the total mass of
the entire belt maybe this dwarf planet
would join the 79 other moons that make
up Jupiter's very faint ring
system next stop would be Mars and now
Jupiter would appear almost four times
larger than usual from Earth now while
the red planet could be lucky enough to
avoid being obliterated by a head-on
impact with Jupiter it it might not make
it out
untouched maybe the newly added Moon
series would slam into it and this
wouldn't be mars' first rodeo either
about 700 million years after the
formation of our solar system a huge
asteroid even larger than series
collided with Mars that Collision tore
Away part of the Martian Hemisphere and
the debris from that asteroid started
orbiting the red planet eventually
forming its Two Moons Phobos and
deos these moons still orbit Mars
today now at 16 million km away Jupiter
would be closing in on the home stretch
from Earth you'd see it bright and clear
as large as the moon and from this point
on you'd start to feel some of the
effects of Jupiter's power powerful
magnetic field this field is the largest
object in the solar system and it's
18,000 times more powerful than
Earth's it would be so strong that it
could trap charged particles and
accelerate them these particles would
damage electronics in our passing
spacecraft and they could potentially
penetrate Earth's atmosphere and
magnetic field and that would be really
bad
news now you were lucky to avoid one of
these Planet killing asteroid collisions
but now you and everyone else on planet
Earth would start to suffer from severe
radiation sickness first you'd be
incapacitated by nausea diarrhea and
vomiting you'd also feel anxiety
confusion and could lose
Consciousness after a few few torturous
hours you'd start to feel okay but then
the final stage would kick in you'd
experience Tremors and convulsions
before ending up in a coma or
worse if somehow you survived this the
ultimate end would draw nearer and
nearer now only 2 million km away the
Great Red Spot would be the same size as
the Moon
and the planet itself would appear eight
times larger than that rock above us
Earth would now be caught in a violent
game of tug-of war between Jupiter and
the sun this could cause tidal heating
all around our planet Earth could become
a hellhole riddled with earthquakes and
volcanic eruptions that would spew
sulfur dioxide gases into space all all
the while Jupiter would be making its
Final
Approach now as close as the Moon it
would occupy 40 times more space in our
night sky and as it crashes into Earth
the atmospheres of both planets would
compress this would rapidly increase the
temperature causing everything on Earth
including the air itself to burst into
flames and in this colossal in Inferno
Earth would burn up in Jupiter's
atmosphere until we fuse with the gas
giant
forever a rogue star is headed straight
for our sun if these two stars slam into
each other it could spell the end of all
life on our
planet How could a rogue star end up in
our solar
system what would this epic Collision
look
like and how much time do you have to
live this is what if and here's what
would happen if a rogue star collided
with the
Sun as the name would suggest Rogue
Stars drift through space they don't
belong to any particular Galaxy or if
they once did they've been ejected from
their homes at some point by supernovas
or two galaxies ramming into each other
whatever it is that sends these Stars
hurdling away from the gravitational
pull of their original galaxies it fires
them off at very high
speeds in order to break free of our own
Milky Way galaxy a star would need to
move as fast as 550 km/ second luckily
our sun is only moving at a mere 200
km/s not nearly fast enough to become
Rogue but these wandering Stars aren't
all that uncommon they may even account
for as many as half of the 200 billion
trillion stars in the universe and one
of them could be headed toward our sun
right
now meet GLE 710 this Rogue dwarf star
is on a trajectory that would bring it
close to our solar system in around 1.3
million years when GLE 710 eventually
reaches us it would enter the outermost
section of our solar system the ort
Cloud at a speed of about
51,500
kmph it could send the icy bodies out
there flying in different directions
maybe even right to toward Earth once it
has reached Neptune the countdown to the
Epic Collision would begin T minus 10
years till the impact with the Sun at
this point you'd better just plan to
live your best life while preparing for
the upcoming
apocalypse the gravitational pull of
Glee 710 would destabilize the orbits of
our planetary neighbors nudging them
left and right
this could go as far as pushing Earth
out of the habitable zone or it could
turn us into a rogue planet after
unceremoniously being catapulted out of
the solar
system after 10 years it would finally
be getting close to Collision time as
each day passes things are only going to
get worse one possibility is that the
Sun and GLE 710 would merge into a red
Nova this would result in a violent
explosion that would unleash nearly half
a million times more light than what the
sun does right now given the amount of
time light takes to travel from the Sun
to the Earth you would be blissfully
unaware of this destructive explosion
for 8 minutes but the moment you do find
out all that light would likely blind
you in a millisecond and then
immediately fry you on the spot that's
because directly behind this blinding
light would be super hot gas this wave
of heat could be powerful enough to wipe
out nearly everything in its path
bye-bye Mercury Venus and yeah Earth
too our atmosphere and oceans would be
completely blasted away this would would
leave our planet as nothing more than a
Barren Rock the explosion would also
have created massive amounts of high
energetic
neutrinos these would be able to boil
you from the inside out Earth would also
be shrouded in Lethal levels of UV and
gamma
radiation even if you somehow managed to
survive the explosion you wouldn't last
long from the harmful effects of all
this radiation you'd have damage to your
eyes skin and even
DNA now if an alien species was watching
this all unfold From A Distant Galaxy
with an incredibly powerful telescope
they'd see a single bright star
surrounded by an excess of reddish
colored gas and the infrared light Left
Behind from the explosion would be
visible for a long time
after but that wouldn't be the only way
all this could possibly go down there is
a possibility there could be a more
peaceful
alternative yeah if the two stars are
moving a bit slower relative to each
other they could end up merging into one
massive New Star as they orbit each
other our sun would strip Mass from its
small companion GLE 710 and swallow it
in a process known as Stellar
cannibalism then this extremely hot and
bright star would be called a blue
straggler though it may sound many times
more peaceful this option would still
likely spell out the end of life on
Earth with our sun now a massive blue
star the habitable zone of our solar
system would be pushed further
away the biggest planet in the solar
system and the smallest star in the
known
universe today they're on a collision
course and Earth might not survive this
meet the star with a catchy name eblm Jo
555- 57a
its gravity is 300 times that of Earth's
and it's about the size of our Saturn
ebl lmj 555- 57a is a red dwarf and the
smallest star we've ever discovered
usually it resides 600 light years away
from us in its own double star
system but not today today it broke
broke the cosmic speed limit and rushed
toward our solar system to meet with the
biggest gas giant in it Jupiter let me
just tell you Jupiter is
huge it's about 11 times larger than
Earth it's even bigger than the red
dwarf star coming its way but because
it's mostly made of hydrogen it's not
massive enough to be a star to start
converting all its hydrogen into helium
and turn into a red dwarf Jupiter would
need to be at least 80 times more
massive than it is
today so what would happen if these two
gas giants
collided well before the interstellar
Red Dwarf could even make it to Jupiter
it would have to pass through the or
Cloud the or cloud is a collection of
icy comets and other bodies on the edge
of our solar system as the smallest star
in the known universe was passing
through this icy debris it would wreak
big havoc in our planetary
neighborhood yeah it would send icy
comets our way and some of them would
start hitting Earth we'd have to think
of a way to protect our planet from this
Comet
shower but time would not be on our side
because the smallest star in the
universe would keep moving toward
Jupiter our Stellar guest might be
smaller in size than Jupiter but it sure
would be more massive eblm Jo
55557 ab's gravitational pull would
start to tug on the planet and don't
forget that we'd now have a second star
in our solar system things would start
getting hot all the heat from the Red
Dwarf plus its strong gravity would make
Jupiter grow in size
the gas Giant's atmosphere would puff up
as all the gases were heating up and
expanding some of Jupiter's atmosphere
would start to escape into space and
toward the Stellar Intruder eventually
all the runaway Jupiter gases would form
a hot ring around eblm Jo 55557 AB it
would look as if we had a black hole in
the solar system only it would be really
bright
the red dwarf star would keep slowly
ripping Jupiter apart now it would be
eating whole chunks of our gas giant for
a moment Jupiter would take the shape of
an American football but soon enough the
star would engulf it entirely sorry
Jupiter you didn't stand a chance but
now we'd be in a real pickle Jupiter
would no longer exist in the solar
system and now we'd have an alien Red
Dwarf star surrounded by a ring of hot
gases our solar system wouldn't be the
same without Jupiter this gas giant
wasn't here for a cool view Jupiter's
gravity usually attracts asteroids and
comets that make it into our planetary
neighborhood it gobbles them up before
they make it further into the solar
system with no Jupiter to protect us
from all the space rocks Earth would be
getting bombarded by all kinds of debris
I see comets asteroids you name it every
day we'd be hit by about 170 meteors
comets and
asteroids that's 10 times more than
what's making it to our planet right now
life here would sure get more dangerous
who knows how long before one really big
asteroid would come and destroy all life
on on our
planet but things would get even
worse having another star in our solar
system would disrupt the orbits of all
the planets at passed including Earth's
of course it would take eblm Jo 55557 AB
millions of years to Rampage all the way
to our sun so you might stay alive long
enough to witness the Epic slow motion
chaos
unless the Red Dwarf sent another planet
on a collision course with us yeah that
would end things much much quicker all
the planetary collisions in the solar
system would create a Rippling effect
the planetary orbits would get disrupted
even more as time passed Earth could
even get knocked out of its orbit
entirely this would send you and
everything else on the planet on a rogue
trip across the universe and without the
sun to give us warmth the Earth would
turn into a frigid lifeless Rock very
soon if you somehow survived up to this
point you wouldn't have very long
now black holes are the gravitational
Monsters of the
universe they are so powerful that
nothing not even light can escape their
grasp one black hole is bad enough but
if you took two black holes and smashed
them into each other they'd be capable
of changing the shape of space
itself how epic would that explosion be
and could it somehow reach
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if two black holes
collided of course we have no means to
capture or control black holes yet so
imagine you're observing one from a
giant telescope here on Earth and
suddenly you notice something strange is
that another black
hole it sure looks like it and it also
looks like these two are about to
collide it turns out that even even
gravitational giants like black holes
occasionally run into each other in the
seemingly vast
Universe are you about to see a nuclear
bomb likee explosion of super siiz
proportions the reality might be a
little disappointing but you still
wouldn't want that Galactic bomb to
detonate anywhere near your
planet bear with me here because to
understand how black holes Collide you
need to arm yourself with a bit of
theory
black holes come in all shapes and sizes
and of course the magnitude of the
Collision would depend on which black
holes are slammed together Stellar Mass
black holes are the most common type
they can have up to 20 solar masses but
could fit in a ball much smaller in
diameter than our
sun okay now let's go back to you
observing this gravitational show
firsthand first you'd see the two black
holes getting a a little closer until
they started to orbit each other they
would begin pulling matter and gas into
a Vortex between them get comfortable
because it could take billions of years
for their centers to
merge but as the two black holes merged
into one they'd wobble a little and then
settle down into a new bigger black
hole now I hope you're not disappointed
with such an explosion free outcome but
wait there's something I haven't
mentioned yet the excess energy from the
Collision would be expelled back into
the universe as gravitational
waves as I mentioned before colliding
black holes can change the shape of the
space around them they do it by Rippling
this space with gravitational
waves Albert Einstein predicted
gravitational waves over a 100 years ago
but scientists didn't observe them until
2015 when the advanced ligo
gravitational wave Observatory finally
detected gravitational waves after 8
years of
operation the cool thing about these
waves is that they affect the distance
between the Sun and the Earth they only
change it by the diameter of a hydrogen
atom you'd need a whole lot of colliding
black holes to really see a difference
but what about super massive black holes
would their Collision be more explosive
these black holes have a mass of at
least hundreds of thousands of times the
mass of our sun but the thing is they
might never even Collide at all two
super massive Giants would get close to
each other and until they reached a
gravitational balance and froze in their
respective
orbits but add another super massive
black hole to the equation and the three
of them could tip over the gravitational
scale and finally Collide not in a
massive cosmic explosion but a silent
merger sending powerful gravitational
waves throughout the
Universe You know despite the fact that
black holes are an Unstoppable
insatiable force from which nothing can
escape we have nothing to fear from
their
Collision what a view the air over here
is especially wait what is is this doing
here this is what if and here's what
would happen if another planet smashed
into
Earth about 50 billion rogue planets are
roaming the Milky Way with no host star
to hold on
to they don't give off any light of
their own and that makes them difficult
to spot last time a stray planetoid the
size of Mars smashed into Earth it
scattered our planet's young crust into
space where gravity glued those
particles into what we now call the
moon this time it would be all Hellfire
and brimstone with no survivors left and
here's a timeline of how things break
down a few weeks before the Collision an
unknown object would appear in the sky
it wouldn't happen overnight no we'd
know something was coming we'd see the
planet slowly growing bigger until one
day it was as big as the Moon it would
seem as if everything was unfolding in a
relatively slow pace but that's only
because of the huge distances involved
out there in space the Rogue Planet
would rush towards us at a speed of 11
km a
second when The Uninvited space Intruder
came into the moon's orbit bad things
would start to happen the gravitational
pull of the alien planet would make the
tides on Earth eight times larger than
they are
now floods would begin to Rampage
through the coastline cities and still
still the mega tsunamis are yet to
come 28 hours before the Collision the
gravity of both planets pulling
themselves towards each other would
speed up the process the incoming Planet
would hit a speed of 60 km a second Mega
tsunamis would plot their way across the
oceans with this would come lightning
storms plus hurricanes and tornadoes so
large they wouldn't have a number on the
category scale if you didn't book
yourself a vacation board a spaceship
that would take you to outer space your
time on this planet would be running
out 3 minutes before the Collision the
Rogue Planet enters the Earth's
atmosphere provided you hadn't already
been killed by the lightning hurricanes
flooding earthquakes or volcanoes you'd
see the rocky Invader completely filling
the sky above
you Nan seconds before the Collision the
atmospheres of both planets would be
compressed together and glow bright ly
it would get so hot that everything on
the side of the earth about to get hit
would instantly
vaporize for the rest of the Earth the
ground would become scorching
[Music]
magma upon impact the Collision would
cause friction between the two
planets while the Hellfire would rush
across Earth's surface the planet's
inner core would be be melting it from
the inside out this would have one big
outcome the Earth would collapse in on
itself the end of the
era if you did manage to get away in a
spaceship you'd see the massive remnants
of both planets catapulted into
different orbits some of them would hit
other planets others would be fired out
of the solar system entirely whatever
was left would form a new asteroid belt
encircling the sun none of this would
give any hint that there was once
intelligent life on planet Earth but hey
you can sleep well knowing that this
won't ever happen well most likely
not see that bright object in the sky
that's Andromeda the closest major
Galaxy to our Milky Way and the most
distant thing you can see with the naked
eye and it's racing towards us at the
rate of 110 km/ second eventually 4
billion years from now Andromeda will
merge with our Milky way in a huge
Galactic
Collision but what if these galaxies
were to collide tomorrow would all the
stars and planets suddenly plow into
each other could our solar system
survive this massive crash and what
would this Galactic light show look like
from Earth this is what if and here's
what would happen if the Milky Way and
the Andromeda galaxy
collided there are at least 100 billion
galaxies in the observable universe all
colliding with each other larger
galaxies merge about every n billion
years while smaller ones slam into each
other even more often wait what about
Dark Energy isn't this hypothesized
Force pulling the universe and
everything in it apart it sure is for
nearby galaxies though gravity takes
over Andromeda and the Milky Way are no
exception they both contain Central
super massive black holes that will
eventually mesh the two star systems
together imagine if that gigantic
Collision were to happen tomorrow what
would that look like Andromeda is Prett
pretty far away it couldn't just
overcome a distance of 2 and 1/2 million
light years in a single day let's assume
that somehow the super massive black
hole in the center of the Milky Way
increased its gravitational pull on
andromeda's black hole and the Big
Crunch happened 4 billion years earlier
than expected what's
next first there would be no Milky Way
and no Andromeda the two spiral galaxies
would become a totally different type of
galaxy an elliptical one you can call
the new Galaxy Mila or mil Andromeda
whichever one you prefer once Andromeda
invaded milky Way's personal space the
Sun and our entire solar system would be
forced to the outskirts of the newly
formed Galaxy 26,000 light years further
away and that's the best case scenario
in the worst case one we might end up in
a galactic
Siberia 160,000 light years away from
Mila
Center what about all the stars in both
galaxies would they collide with each
other some of them would but even though
Milky Way counts around 250 billion
stars and Andromeda has over a trillion
of them all these stars are separated by
light years of empty space it's unlikely
that many of them would merge instead
they'd just get scattered into different
orbits ooh I forgot to mention we
invited a third Galaxy to this party the
triangulum Galaxy or m33 a smaller
satellite Galaxy of Andromeda this is
shaping up to be a massive Galactic
mashup for us earthlings this would look
just incredible the bright core of the
new Super Galaxy would set the night sky
Ablaze eventually the two super massive
black holes at the center of these
galaxies would come so close to each
other that they themselves would merge
all the gas taken up by this monstrous
black hole would form a bright quazar at
the center of the Galaxy another
spectacular show for us here on Earth
too bad in reality our planet won't live
long enough to see any of it by the time
Andromeda slams into the Milky Way the
Sun Sun would have already turned into a
red giant and swallowed up the entire
Earth but that's a story for another
what
[Music]
if it's been 30 days since Uranus first
appeared in the
sky at first it looked like our moon had
found itself a stellar
partner but then we understood something
much much bigger was headed our
way what caused Uranus to become so
unstable